hi my name's Michelle you may know me as
lab muffin beauty science or just that
weirdo who really really likes
exfoliants so that's what I'm talking
about today exfoliating why am I so
obsessed with exfoliation well it's one
of the easiest things that you can add
to your routine and it has such big
effects when I first started getting
into skin care my skin was dull and
covered in blackheads and whiteheads my
post inflammatory hyperpigmentation
which is the brown marks that stay on
your skin after the pimples go away this
will take forever to fade away
adding exfoliates changed my skin
dramatically all the stuff I'm going to
be talking about today is also in my
exfoliation guide which you can download
for the low low price of zero dollars
after you download the guide you can
unsubscribe at any time if you don't
want updates but if you want to know
about new blog posts and videos right
when they come out which is about once a
week then you'll probably want to stay
on the list either way you'll get the
exfoliation guide which has all of this
info and a whole bunch of other advice
in a handy reference format which you
can also print out as well if you want
let's talk about exfoliating your skin
has a whole bunch of layers the main
true are the dermis which lies below the
epidermis the epidermis is really cool
it acts as a really good barrier between
your insights and the dangers of the
outside world one of the main ways it
does this is by shedding dead skin cells
quite quickly so that any bacteria or
microorganisms that can harm you can't
really get a foothold your skin has an
outer layer of dead skin cells around 15
to 20 cells thick this is called the
stratum corneum and it gets replaced
around once every two weeks
you shouldn't even notice it coming off
if everything is working properly but
sometimes it doesn't work properly
things like aging hormones changes in
your diet changes in the weather and
even using the wrong skin care products
can slow down your skin's natural
exfoliation processes and when this
happens you can end up with clogged
pores breakouts
patches wrinkles and dull skin you can
help your skin along by exfoliating
[Music]
there are two main categories of
exfoliation physical exfoliation and
chemical exfoliation both are great they
each have their pros and cons and you
can use them together as well
[Music]
physical exfoliation is also called
manual or mechanical exfoliation it's
when you buff away dead skin cells a bit
like sanding down wood but hopefully
much much gentler physical exfoliation
is what most people think of when people
talk about exfoliation things like
scrubs and brushes are physical
exfoliants physical exfoliation has a
few advantages firstly the results are
immediate so you can quickly see if
you've exfoliated enough it's also easy
to adjust how gentle or harsh of
physical exfoliant is you just press
harder or buff your skin for longer
there's also a lower chance of an
unexpected reaction because it only
works on the surface of your skin on the
other hand physical exfoliants do only
work on the upper layers of your skin
it's also pretty easy to scrub too hard
and a lot of people purposely scrub too
hard because it feels nice and it feels
like it's working but unfortunately this
causes irritation and over exfoliation
which can make your skin break out and
feel sensitive so the opposite of what
you want to do chemical exfoliation
involves applying a product that helps
skin cells come off more easily without
directly buffing them off some chemical
exfoliants loosen layers of dead skin
cells so that they come off more easily
and in smaller pieces sometimes they'll
act as chemical messengers to change how
quickly skin cells are produced so the
stratum corneum will renew itself more
quickly chemical exfoliation has a lot
of advantages they tend to work more
evenly than physical exfoliants and it's
harder to use them incorrectly a lot of
chemical exfoliants also have additional
benefits on top of exfoliating too like
fading pigment and calming down
inflammation but compared to physical
they tend to be a bit more slow to work
which means you have to be more patient
when you're checking if a new product is
working there's also a higher chance of
irritation and allergic reactions since
they penetrate deeper into your skin
some of them can also make your skin
more sensitive to the sun's harmful UV
rays now that we know what the true
categories of exfoliants are let's look
at the most common ones the most common
physical exfoliants are probably scrubs
scrubs can have a wide range of
different scrubbing particles that vary
from gentle to harsh
some of the gentler particles and scrubs
are plastic microbeads her Hoeber beads
castor sugar and ground oatmeal plastic
microbeads generally don't break down in
the environment and they're too small to
be filtered out from sewage so it's best
to avoid them so you don't contribute to
plastic waste in the environment a lot
of brands are phasing them out as well
so it's very easy to find alternatives
harsher scrubbing particles include
coffee grounds chunky sugar and salt
crystals and crush nut kernels I
personally wouldn't recommend using
these on your face unless you're quite
experienced with exfoliation because
it's really easy to go too hard and end
up with irritated skin an irritation can
cause breakouts and make existing
breakouts even worse
but these harshest scrubs can be really
good for sanding down rough patches on
your body as well as buying scrub
products from the store you can also
make your own scrubs by mixing ground
oatmeal sugar salt or coffee grounds
with oil or water when you're using
scrubs
I recommend buffing lightly in small
circles for a longer time rather than go
really hard for a shorter period it
tends to give you more even and thorough
exfoliation without overly irritating
your skin a type of product that I
really like for physical exfoliation
that's similar to a scrub but isn't
really a scrub is the peeling gel
peeling gels also call curmudgeons they
have ingredients like cellulose or
carbon is that roll up and turn into
these soft scrubbing fibers when they
interact with your skin they're really
gentle but really thorough for
exfoliating I really really like them
for getting rid of dead skin flakes
without irritating your skin or taking
off any bits of skin
that aren't quite ready to come off yet
I really like the peeling gels from the
faceshop
they have one called white jewel peeling
gel and that works really really well
there was also a peeling gel from
skin-food that I use for a really long
time called pineapple peeling gel I
really liked it it has some scrubbing
greens in there as well as the peeling
gel fibers and I found that it gave me a
really nice thorough exfoliation the
packaging was a bit annoying because it
was hard to get the last bits out but
overall that was like a really minor
complaint there are also a ton of tools
that you can use for physical
exfoliation face cloths face brushes and
contract sponges are all really good
physical exfoliants when you're using
these tools you need to make sure that
they stay clean because any dead skin
cells that accumulate on them will act
as food for bacteria and mold bacteria
and mold aren't good for your skin
they're going to lead to breakouts and
infections to avoid this make sure you
clean your tools after you use them and
let them dry out in between using them
and also replace them regularly I've
used cleansing brushes in the past and
the foreo tool as well and I quite liked
using them but they don't really fit
well into my routine my skin's also
really sensitive when there's things
like bacteria building up on beauty
products and Charles and stuff like that
so I'm a little bit scared of cleansing
tools but I know a lot of people who use
them and they find them really good
[Music]
there are a few different categories of
chemical exfoliants that you can find in
skincare
the most common chemical exfoliants are
the hydroxy acids in general these work
by speeding up how quickly skin cells
renew themselves and loosening the
layers of dead skin cells so that they
come off more easily in smaller chunks
they've also been found to even out skin
tone and lessen wrinkles the most common
ones are the alpha hydroxy acids like
glycolic acid lactic acid and mandelic
acid these are usually recommended if
you've got dry skin but I have oily skin
and I found them really really useful
for smoothing out my skin and fading
hyperpigmentation
alpha hydroxy acids work most
effectively at a lower pH so usually
products with a pH below
four and a concentration of between four
and ten percent are recommended when
you're just starting out with these
antes for air chase I really like lactic
acid there's a whole bunch of lattic
acid products that you can get as well
which are really good so for example
there's one from the ordinary there's
one that I really like from ultra suta
khals I also like the weaker tone
estelle hydroxy acid exfoliants like
Pixy glow tonic and crave Beauty
callaloo yeah because you can use them
more regularly without worrying about
irritation and you can use them I guess
you can incorporate them into your love
routine a bit more easily as well so you
don't have to worry about combining it
with other irritating things because
overall the irritation ends up being a
bit less if you're just starting with
exfoliation I wouldn't recommend one of
the stronger wash off AJ products yet
but if you're a bit further along and
you've got quite a lot in your routine I
like having these wash off products
because then you can just insert it at
some point during the week and you have
more space to move your other products
around so the ones that I've tried so
far kate Somerville's exfoli kate and
drunk elephants baby facial and both of
these seem to work pretty well I tend to
use them just before a shower I use them
like a mask and then I wash it off in
the shower salicylic acid is often
called beta hydroxy acid and because
it's more oil soluble than alpha hydroxy
acids it's often recommended for people
who have oily skin and acne there's been
a study that found that pH matters a lot
less for salicylic acid and it can
exfoliate effectively even around pH 7
which is neutral I have a video which
was actually my first video that talks
more about pH and acids that I've linked
in the caption if you're interested in
the finer details of how all of this
works in terms of beta hydroxy acid
exfoliants I always recommend Paula's
Choice 2% BHA liquid it's got a really
liquid texture it goes on really nicely
it shrinks blackheads and it's really
good at calming down pimples as well and
it lasts forever a newer type of hydroxy
acid is the poly hydroxy acid or PHA
this includes ingredients like lecture
Bionic acid and glue kono lactone
they're less well researched but they're
supposed to work as well as other
hydroxy acids but with less irritation
one of the problems with hydroxy acid
exfoliants is that alpha hydroxy acid
have been found to make your skin more
Sun sensitive so it will end up burning
faster this sensitivity isn't just when
the alpha hydroxy acid is on your face
so you don't need to only use them at
night but you do need to make sure that
you wear sunscreen every day when you
have alpha hydroxy acids in your routine
as well as for a week after you stop
using them
there are also some exfoliants that use
enzymes which can break down proteins
helping your skin exfoliate the most
common ones in skincare products are
bromelain from pineapple / pain from
papaya and act in attained from kiwi
fruit these exfoliants are usually used
like a mask you put them on for around
10 minutes before you wash them off you
can DIY an enzyme exfoliant by mashing
up the raw fruit and putting it on your
face canned fruit doesn't work as well
because when you can a fruit you have to
heat it up to a really high temperature
and this denatures or changes the shape
of the enzymes which means that they
don't work anymore I'm really lazy with
my enzyme peels so I usually just DIY
them if I've been eating kiwi fruit for
example I'll just save the skins and
then keep it in the fridge and rub it on
my face right before I go and have a
shower
[Music]
how much exfoliation your skin needs
depends on your skin type skin
conditions and the rest of your skincare
routine I've put more detailed
recommendations for different skin types
and conditions dry skin oily skin aging
skin acne prone skin sensitive skin and
so on in my free exfoliation guide but
here are some general tips when you
start using exfoliants I usually
recommend that you pick one gentle
exfoliant and start using it around once
a week and then if that goes well then
start increasing how frequently you use
it so start using it twice a week three
times a week and upwards then if you
still want more exfoliation you can add
a second exfoliant from a different
category so if you started with a
chemical exfoliant you would add a
physical exfoliant next or if you
started on a physical exfoliant you
would add a chemical exfoliant you
should be waiting a few weeks before you
add a new product to lower the chance of
your skin having a bad reaction it also
lets you see which products are actually
working which means it will be easier on
your wallet
and it'll stop your skincare routine
from jacking up way too much of your
time you should always start and build
up your routine slowly it's always much
better to under exfoliate than to over
exfoliate because it can take weeks for
over exfoliated skin to finally recover
when you exfoliate too much your skin
gets sensitive tight red and overly
shiny if you see any of these issues
start to crop up on your face then you
should stop exfoliating for at least a
few days and who your skin starts
recovering and then if you want to start
again again start really really slowly
going slow is especially important when
you're starting on new products and
especially if your skin is quite
sensitive
make sure you patch test new products
before you put them on your whole face
so if anything goes wrong it's much
easier to hide and ill hurt less and
that's a quick guide to exfoliation I've
put a link to my free exfoliation guide
in the caption below if you want all of
this info and much more and a guide that
you can print out and refer to when
you're working out your skin care
routine I also have more product
recommendations and short reviews in
there and I've linked some products in
the caption as well if you like this
video please like and subscribe to my
channel you can also find out more about
the science behind skincare and other
beauty products on my blog which is lab
math and calm if you want more regular
beauty tips you can also follow me on
Facebook and Instagram see you next time
for more beauty and science
[Music]